hey everybody it's Friday again and it's
time for another movie retrospective we
pulled a pretty obscure one out of our
asses this time actually has been on the
list for a long long yeah it has there's
actually kind of an interesting story
about how I ended up seeing this and how
you ended up saying cuz I had actually
never heard of it yeah but you kept
telling me about this movie that you saw
when I were a kid didn't know the name
and you didn't know the name of it and
all you've remembered was just this one
scene toward the end that like you said
really scare the crap out of you guys
guys find the escape from a haunted
house and he went down in front of the
statue of a gargoyle and he started
sinking down into the Flex payment and
and I remembered other parts of it too
but I didn't realize that they were from
the same movie right I gotcha yeah that
happens to me too sometimes yeah this is
a good movie and I think it was better
than I actually think it was better than
Amityville Horror this actually came in
a little bit before Amityville Horror
about a year before yeah but it's weird
because I kept I was really gonna help
you find out what this movie was and so
I kept googling like different
iterations of I'm thinking the movie has
many different names and I finally found
it yeah it's a usually it's more
commonly known as the believable right
um also known as house of evil right or
I've also seen it called the evil below
yeah it came out in about May 1978 I
believe and you know I was just
researching it today not a lot of [ __ ]
about it um even on the Wikipedia page
and stuff like know there's like a plot
synopsis but there's really no like
background information on it like and
you know behind the scenes type stuff
it's actually I think it's a Roger
Corman production or he had something to
do with the production of it until very
recently it was only available on VHS
yeah until shout factory actually put it
out on a double bill DVD like Roger
Corman cos it's double feature you gotta
give it and it's on there with another
movie that's called twice dead okay from
1988 which I haven't seen and I've heard
isn't as good as this one by a long way
I would sometimes get this movie can
fused with legend hell house it's kind
of a similar vibe I would see legend of
Hell house like in the 80s and then and
maybe the early 90s and expect it to be
this movie right but I didn't know the
name of this movie how I saw that I saw
this new in a theater when it came out I
don't think and I don't think it was 78
I think it was 77 I think it was right
after star wars because I gonna tell you
how how I remember this my little
babysitter my cutie little baby consider
named Kimmy took me to see this and this
is back in the 70s and Kimmy was about
13 or 14 this is back when you know we
were kind of like free-range children
they don't do this kind of [ __ ] in here
um for those days but your parents would
give you over to young teenage girls and
they'd take care of you it was awesome
that I was you know eight yeah and by
eight and she used to take me over to
her house and all her little teenage
friends and sit around in there and they
had all the blacklight posters and
they'd be playing Led Zeppelin and
smoking pot you know I don't really know
what that was and then they'd take me to
the murders that was awesome man they
pass you around kiss on you and [ __ ] and
cuddle and put on your hair and [ __ ]
yeah like your little you were eight
yeah you're the eight and it's just like
you know it was just like your like
hearts and [ __ ] going up on top my head
girls Kimmy Kimmy looked just like
Princess Leia and that's why I know it
happened right after Star Wars and
there's another clue that there was a
connection to Star Wars with this movie
there's a scene where a dog runs down
the hallway yeah and there are people
screaming and running from it and the
dog is growling and simultaneously
making the sound of a TIE fighter
because the guy who did the sound in
this movie it also did it for Star Wars
so he used his tie fighter effect is
like I said there's not a huge amount of
it there's probably about 30 or 40
different like horror blogs that have
done little retrospectives honor
particularly after the shout factory a
double feature came out and you're not
the only person to notice that there
were a couple of other mentions of the
TIE fighter so yeah which is actually
very funny but this movie it's
very much in the vein it seems like it's
kind of forgotten it's really one that
doesn't get much attention even though
it's actually pretty good and I mean I'm
super into mid 70s haunted house movies
that's like my favorite horror sub-genre
like no question and even the crappy
ones all sit and wash them because
there's just something about 70s haunted
house movies that I really like but this
one I'm not gonna say that it's better
than like burnt offerings I'm not gonna
say it's better than the changeling or
legend of Hell house but it's in that
vein and it's almost as good as that I
think um you can tell it's pretty low
budget it's almost looks today almost
kind of looks like made-for-tv and i
Thea it looked like really high-quality
made-for-tv even in those days yeah but
it didn't matter because it did have
some pretty gruesome death scenes and it
was scary as [ __ ]
in those days it's a lot scarier than
Amityville Horror it delivered a lot
more than Amityville Horror you actually
get to meet the devil the devil talks to
you it's pretty cool and pretty like oh
there's new scenes in almost every death
no not quite no there's not I don't
really remember any nude scenes in there
other than not them black girls clothes
got ripped off they did but she still
had a bra oh yeah okay alright and do
you know who that was
I'm pretty sure that was Lynne moody and
wasn't she and scream Blacula scream
that's wrongly yeah she looked familiar
yeah Richard Crenna is also in this yeah
probably most famous for the Rambo
movies but he's been in tons of other
[ __ ] too um oh my goodness
can't shake it ins like behind us like
going hey pay attention oh yeah but uh
yeah so there was actually some sort of
big-name kind of actors in this now
since you mentioned seeing the devil
yeah the last like 10 minutes the 10
minutes sequence of this yeah where you
get to see the legendary character actor
I think his name is Victor Buono and
he's playing the devil yeah white suit
and everything do it slowly
no I'm not okay I have heard now the
ending sequence of this movie is very
love it or hate it
I've seen people on both ends of the
spectrum that were just like they just
thought it was a great ending or some
people thought it was a stupid
ending and I've heard that there were
back in the day some VHS prints or
copies of this floating around that had
the last sequence taken off because
rumor had it that Roger Corman was like
I guess the ending didn't test well so
there were some versions that didn't
have that ending which is now it's like
makes me really curious like so how did
they end it then like what did they put
at the end I would have been standing a
lot of proud of it and ending a lot like
Amityville Horror maybe how many of you
or ripped that ending off for the dog
falls underneath the ground but then
they come and save the dog the dog comes
out it's all covered in black it's gonna
be something like that yeah that was the
problem with Amityville Horror you know
there was the Red Room and then falling
down into the the Blood tar pit or
whatever it was it was never quite
answered what the Red Room and the devil
face was all about he just left it vague
not in this movie they actually deliver
they show you what's underneath the
place yeah and I mean like I said just
like a lot of the haunted house type
movies in the 70s this was actually
filmed this that was actually a real
house of tesha at college it might still
be standing there I'm not really sure
it's in New Mexico so they usually yeah
but California yeah no it was New Mexico
and and it was this huge like really
really big cavernous kind of creepy
house yeah and it just they'd put
cobwebs all over I mean the premise of
the movie very similar to other type of
haunted house movies there's like a is
amiss CJ he's played by Richard Crenna
and his wife who was a doctor and
they're buying this house for cheap
because no one's lived there for years
and years and they're gonna turn it into
a drug rehab center yeah so they have
some of their patients like recovering
drug addicts and stuff that are okay now
and like some of their friends and stuff
so they've all come to this place over
weekend to like clean it all up and get
it all ready for people to come there
and [ __ ] like that and then you know
hauntings ensue yeah pretty much I'm
gonna say this is like a pretty I like
how it's more yeah it shows some
gruesome deaths it's not super gory
no I wouldn't say this but you thought
it was back in those days yeah it was
just bloody scene long image is like
suggested yeah
what about it actually burned up people
dead people just people getting
electrocuted people dying from weird
psychokinesis
you know things flying and hitting them
yeah well I guess that happens people
being drugged off into shadows you're
not sure what did it it's pretty neat
and one thing that was good about it is
that the cast is pretty tight oh yeah
it's a bunch of cute girls well I'll
call them girls you know they actually
ranged that they range across the age
range which they did back then in the
70s and then a variety of guys you know
got the intelligent older white guy you
got the artificial kind of imitation
what was his name Burt Reynolds he's
like a fake Burt run they had the Burt
Reynolds mustache the Burt Reynolds he
was a good guy actually doing a Burt
Reynolds impersonation yeah he served at
a Crocodile Dundee here then going on to
everybody
well that was a Burt Reynolds hands like
smelling abandoned I guess that's where
they got that from although I think was
smoking actually smoking the ban it
might have predated that that there was
a certain styles in the 70s and there
was certain kind of character types in
the seventies especially out in
California is almost kind of a
subculture to be like oh damn Burt
Reynolds with the [ __ ] mustache and
and I had yeah it's like it's like the
Burt Reynolds code I didn't but Burt
Reynolds was a member of that cult
actually he didn't invent that that he
was just he was a member he was an
acolyte of a cult that was named after
him in retrospect right I got you yeah
California kind of oh what's up guy now
you know I'm getting a big brush yeah
I'm here to bust a [ __ ] I'm here to have
sex with all you women you know seems
like that whether you want to or not
yeah I'd have to say one thing when you
were talking about like seventies
fashions and stuff and your cryin is in
this and he plays I think he's a physics
professor right yeah and he brings like
one of his students slash lover yeah
long with him yeah and the 70s man the
pants yeah we're so high and so tight
I'm like a leer down did they get into
those pants ah I mean I remember people
barring those but you had to be like
pretty scrawny to get into this boy got
a member you know and you couldn't have
any belly yeah you had to be like pretty
much skeletal a lot of men and women a
lot of the seventies kind of fashion was
built around real skinny kind of yeah
yeah and then like you know I don't want
to co course pretty much is
cocaine-fueled and you couldn't wear and
you couldn't wear I guess that's why
under Rawls was a big thing because you
couldn't wear underwear with that [ __ ]
because you get VPL you know what I mean
and I think bras were banned during the
filming of this movie I don't think they
really were so many so many nipples yeah
um but you know like you said I kind of
like you can tell that it's sort of
low-budget but in a way and this happens
sometimes particularly with some 70s
haunted house movies the fact that they
don't have enough money to show like big
splashy special yeah X that usually
works in its favor that helped it
because the one scene and I think you
just mentioned it with the girl just
getting dragged up into the shadows like
on the stairs yeah you see something in
there okay well originally that was
supposed to be she was supposed to get
dragged upstairs by like a little
monster right but then they didn't have
the budget to show it so they showered
like and to me that's all like a lot
more effective because you don't know
what happened to her yeah it's like and
you can like imagine like the worst
thing you can you can see the feet in
the legs
yeah I don't want to spoil it but you
can see kind of the feet in the legs but
it's probably better not to see it
because seeing a cheap ass 1970s monster
probably would have spoiled it yeah kind
of like some people you know we're
complaining about like alien vs.
predator Requiem you know why it's so
dark I can't see anything
the special effects on those aliens the
price so bad you didn't want to see him
yeah just a hint at what was going on I
mean look at what happens with jaws you
know they're [ __ ] mechanical shark
brokes the Steven spielberger is like
well we won't show it as much and look
it made the movie a [ __ ] classic one
of the best movies ever because you
don't see it and it's like much more
threatening when you just cut a lot of
it a lot of these monster costumes that
they use in the movies if you saw in
normal daylight especially up close and
filled them
probably be on par with what Power
Rangers some of the Power Rangers
officers on the bad guys there felt like
that it's just not quite Gamera level
but yeah that's just what difference the
difference is the lighting and how
they're shot and how everything is
edited you know and the pacing to the
Edit is what makes those monsters look
believable and in the 70s they just
didn't have the filmography they didn't
have the film technology didn't have the
equipment to do that yeah and it just
couldn't get it right so big family
seventies would have been alien 1 yeah
and it's just brief glimpses of the damn
thing and it makes it creepier because
you never you can't get a handle on like
you can see it enough to give you an
idea of what it might look like and how
creepy it is but you don't you can't get
a handle on how big it is yeah anything
alien wants some of the deleted scenes
or they show the xenomorph for extended
periods of time it looks terrible
yeah it looks and I think that happens
with any kind of and here's the thing -
and I always felt like if you're going
to make a low-budget horror movie you
know nowadays most people you know or
for the past 10 20 years people making
zombie movies because they're easy to
make you just like get some of your
friends rip up their clothes slap some
flesh and blood on their face and you're
good to go but I always felt like it
would probably be better to make a
haunted house movie where you don't
really show much of anything like you
know normal activity for example where
it's like you don't really you don't
show any go she don't show you monster
it's like so everything is just like
atmosphere and it's just like creepy and
stuff and then you don't really show
anything or you just do little hints of
things and then that way because even if
you you know even if you're doing a
zombie movie it's low-budget if the
makeup looks like [ __ ] then no one's
then no one's gonna take the movie
seriously right so you might as I feel
like you might as well go the suggestive
RTA party route if you don't have the
money to show it and you know I deal I
think would be the changeling the way
yes yes that's what I mean that that
shows essential and like I said the
granddaddy of all haunted house movies
the haunting from 1963 essentially
showed nothing and yet it was so so
creepy [ __ ] is the way it was shot like
weird angles and [ __ ] like that
if you're gonna do it go that route
because that doesn't cost anything and
if you do it right it can be way
creepier
than actually showing a monster I think
now that said returning to the evil one
thing I am gonna ding this for you know
as soon as they get to this house and
you know the realtor tells them and I
love this in the opening scene where the
where the two doctors are like looking
around the place before the other people
get there and they're there with the
realtor and he tells them that the
original owner Amelia Vargas he built it
over like a fumarole like a sulfur pit
yeah where you're like ding-ding
Sigalert which I kind of love but then
almost immediately the the doctor the
the woman the wife she starts seeing
apparitions now I wish that they had
kept this apparition a little more
ambiguous yeah they showed it for too
long because I think like the first
couple shots of it were fine because
they were just like kind of hazy and
it's like it looked like a person but
not really good but then like later on
it kind of went like Disney haunted
house like where you could kind of see
him and he was like walking he was all
white and stuff and it's like you know I
kind of wish that they had toned that
down a little bit but it's not you know
it's not a huge for the 70s that was
good though that was a girl remember
saying there's a kid you know in the 70s
and it was impressive and then the
audience seemed to be kind of impressed
with it the standards were different
then they were that particular effect
didn't age well but in its day it was
just like oh wow people were Saira
member people in the theater being
afraid that this movie was scaring him
it does have like a really creepy vibe I
think yeah it was um
later on I saw a medieval horror and I
kind of think Kimmy took took me to see
that one too I think
yeah you were took you to see all that
79 79 yeah well yeah she's my babysitter
for several years we had four or five
four years maybe yeah so yeah she took
me see a lot of stuff and she was a she
lived two houses over okay so it wasn't
like he wasn't like we had to import her
over from the other side of town or
anything she she lived on the block with
us gave me from the block Kimmy Kimmy
look just like a like a 14 year old at
that time 13 14 year old Carrie Fisher
but she had the buds yeah just long hair
in the middle yeah looks like I don't
know she was only like she's not really
only a few years older than me now I'm
thinking about it
yeah like of what like a five or six
year dance that's that's nothing yeah
but yeah that's the thing so I I kind of
feel like this movie um I really like I
think that the way the house is shot
like the [ __ ] that happens and I think
it's like really creepy and the house
contributes because the house is like
super like cavernous and it's empty
because it's you know no one's been in
there a long time and they're you know
cleaning it up before they bring in
furniture or whatever so it's just like
all these empty hallways this big empty
basement and all this [ __ ] and there's
also kind of a little bit of you know I
mentioned the ghosts before the doctor
is the only one that can see it and the
reason for this is because she's the
only one that believes in God yeah you
catch that that's why she's the only one
that can see it the other ones can't so
there's kind of a whole thing about
there's a whole faith
type of thing like you know they're
lying a story and I think they're kind
of equate equating that also to kinda
like the female psychic sensitivity
angle to in other words like the witch
theory yeah that's like women are more
prone to being psychic they're more
prone to being witches they're more
prone they're more open more open to the
spiritual world
so they know about God you know I think
it was kind of almost kind of like a
druid type thing going on with it cuz it
was 70s you know and that was kind of
popular in it and in certain the hippie
circles you know hippy spiritualism and
Jesus and druid type magic stuff was all
just part of that same and I should read
that this has that whole and we probably
mentioned it before in Sephora shows
about a haunting this has that whole
very common trope it's common in horror
movies it's coming on pretty much every
episode of a haunting where she's like
hey I see a ghost and hey he's trying to
tell us something above a block and then
her husband is like made sure she's a
doctor yeah yeah and he go come on now
no mansplaining and condescending and
another kind of [ __ ] until the end of
like see ya and plus I should say too
this isn't really spoiling anything but
he's the one that's responsible for all
I can I can understand oh I can
understand why they did that though
because well yeah if everyone jumped on
board then yeah yeah if everybody jumps
on board then the tensions gone there
isn't any cuz there can't be constant
actually there has to be conflict right
between the characters yeah I know why
they do it it just it's just it's funny
because it's like they do it so often
that it's like become a clique I would
drive put this movie very very close to
say the legacy yeah that's another one
that it wrote similar Magus II kind of
like changeling legend to hell house
burnt-offerings
yeah an evil [ __ ] yeah yeah I think
better than Amityville Horror yeah you
said you liked it better yeah it's got
more of a creepy atmosphere I think I'm
just I mean
Amityville Horror I I like it but I feel
like I
I only like it because I saw it a lot
when I was a kid and it scared me when I
was like seven part of the power of a
medieval Horrors that you're watching it
and before you even went to see the
movie you heard that it was babies and
it was Stram power to it really kind of
you kind of cut em evil a little more
slack
yeah because really I already vote when
you really break it down so it looks
like a made-for-tv movie not much
happens in it people gets yeah not much
happens in it really
it's weird cuz we just watched it like I
remember a bunch of [ __ ] happening you
know what I mean I was like the pig and
the [ __ ] tar and all this yeah but we
watched it like just probably a few
months ago maybe six months a year and I
was like wow really not a lot happens in
this it's kind of just a lot of talking
and walking around there but the evil is
action-packed compared to that it is
it's actually very well paced it starts
out a little slow but no not as opposed
to I think yeah like it's just kind of
building up like the opening scene with
the caretaker and all of that so it
starts out kind of slow but after the
people get there it doesn't really [ __ ]
around I mean you know pretty ish and
another really good thing about this
movie you can watch it right now for
free on YouTube and it's a good copy yes
I'll put a lane
in there yeah somebody some very nice
person has put it out there and it's an
idea and it's straight through and
there's no ads in it and you can watch
it for free and see what you think about
the end because like I said it's kind of
I really like the end I liked it it was
a 70s weird it was a very 70s ending and
it just fit in with what I remember 70s
culture is good it but it almost remind
is gonna sound kind of off-the-wall to
like other horror fans but it all just
reminded me of the ending of the Lucci
of Fulgham abhi the gates of hell yeah I
think when it needs of hell yeah I dunno
I don't think you did but it actually
kind of reminded which is kind of or
maybe it was the beyond I can't remember
now but um but for years I didn't know
what this movie was I just remembered
little snippets of it and I didn't put
them all together I just remember that
with guys sinking down into the mud no
yeah and that gargoyle looking down on
him is pretty creepy so that's it but
that's how I found it by googling
different iterations of the phrase guy
sinking in mud yeah gargoyle statue
watching and then finally but yeah it's
it's got to it's got like two or three
different titles it's usually just
called the evil if you you know google
the evil in 1978 you'll find it Shout
Factory has it out on DVD like I said I
might get that Roger Corman cult
classics the other movie that's on it is
called twice dead which has Todd bridges
from different [ __ ] story but that
was from 1988 and I thought it was I'm
seeing that I don't know I guess it's a
haunted house movie but I'm not really
sure it's funny because one of the
channels did we watch this on 42nd
Street films channel or was that a
different channel I was looking at I
think was 40 seconds to have it it might
have been but there yeah there's like a
channel on YouTube called 42nd Street
films and he's got like all he's really
obscure [ __ ] 70s horror some of our
made-for-tv I'm sure and so I've been
watching him because like I said
seventies haunted house movies I don't
give a [ __ ] if they're crappy I'm just
gonna sit and watch him so I watched one
last night called House of the Dead
which actually wasn't even about a house
it was like an anthology movie about a
mortuary and like a creepy mortuary guy
that was like telling the story of how
each person died and it was like some
kind of like Twilight Zone kind of
it was actually pretty good it was kind
of cheesy most never bad those movies
are bad and then I saw another [ __ ]
Barbara Stanwyck in it but I can't
report the name of it was but I was
actually pretty good but yeah so if you
haven't seen it like I said this one is
kind of a deep cut it doesn't really get
discussed all that much when you're
talking about seventies haunted house
nobody knows about this yeah it's kind
of forgotten but it's actually pretty
good like I said it's it's I'm gonna say
it's like B grade that's like not a pin
with change languor burnt-offerings but
it's like pretty it's pretty good it's
on same level technically I would say
but technically be on the same level as
Amityville
yeah yeah so if you like a MIDI really
good like those type of movies then
you'll probably be into this together
like that's some good acting like I said
it's not super super gory so if you
don't like that yeah yeah you don't have
to worry about it it's cool but yeah so
anyway we will wrap up our latest review
remember if you liked the show to like
share subscribe on all your social media
share with all your friends if you'd
like to financially support the show you
can go to our patreon page which is
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast or
go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast wordpress.com and there's a link
in the sidebar to a PayPal account and
remember our regular episodes come out
every Tuesday and our movie reviews come
out every Friday so check them out we
will see you next time
bye